moments ago you made a decision to click
on this video maybe YouTube has been
gently poking you with suggestions to
watch this or maybe it's party routine
whatever the reason we hope the decision
was an easy one to make
but even if the decision was easy the
steps it took to execute that choice the
information you needed to gather were
not simple from reading the title to
physically clicking the link to settling
back into a comfortable position your
body had to coordinate a ton of
processes using chemical and electrical
signals to quickly send instructions all
over the place these signals are rooted
in your nervous system a reflection of
your multicellular complexity life in
the micro cosmos comes with its own
choices though and while they may not
have to coordinate multiple limbs
single-celled eukaryotes are protists
still have decisions to make that got
places to be things to do and they don't
have a brain to help them all they've
got is the one cell to deal with all of
life's complications
microbiologists have been fascinated by
the way protists respond to their
environment for more than a century and
so naturally that has led some
scientists to try and provoke a response
like James our master of microscopes
using a piece of hair to poke these
centres in 1906 a zoologist named
Herbert Spencer Jennings published
behavior of the lower organisms a 366
page book containing sections with
titles like the daily life of Paramecium
and reactions of infusoria to the
electrical current nestled among
descriptions of the many organisms and
behaviors he observed was a section
documenting the waste enters responded
when he injected Carman into the
or around them Carmen is a red dye and
apparently it's something that stenches
don't like very much like our Stander's
the subjects of Jennings experiment did
not particularly revel in this irritant
in our case you can see this denters
trying to act like everything is normal
but with repeated poking they start to
contract evading the troublesome hair
but also missing out on opportunities to
gather passing food they stay contracted
for a short period but eventually they
emerge and extend back to their original
length in Jennings case the Stentor is
also attempted to ride out this irritant
but when that failed those organisms
then began to contort and twist to the
side and in that way the stem ters could
attempt to evade the Karman while still
focusing on what's truly important food
this avoidance reaction is a common one
among protists in the same text Jennings
describes the tendency of some organisms
to avoid light similar to this trick
hello phylum here those changes in
brightness that you see are coming from
the microscope as the diaphragm on the
condenser opens up allowing more light
to enter the slide as the slide quickly
gets brighter you can see the trick Ella
phylum trying to swim away
this organism isn't that well studied so
we don't know exactly why it's trying to
avoid the light some microbes definitely
seek out dark areas to avoid predators
so that's the possible explanation
the light itself may also be harmful to
the organism whatever the reason this
trick Ella phylum isn't alone among
protists one of Stentor kuru Lisa's many
compelling traits is its
photosensitivity
inside its unicellular trumpet-shaped
body our photosensitive pigment granules
called a stentorian that in the presence
of light drive electrical changes in the
plasma membrane
and reversed the movements of its cilia
transporting the organism away of course
there are also protists that seek out
light like the photosynthetic Euglena
that rely on sunlight to make their food
even then there are subtleties in their
response which Jennings observed and
described while the Euglena and his
experiments sought out the light as
expected if the light was too strong or
brought on too suddenly the euglena
sought shadier refuge another protest
that captured Jennings attention was the
Paramecium that seemingly simple
organism that has captivated many
scientists because of its hidden
complexities here you can see the
Paramecium on this slide in their own
series of avoidance reactions and the
main thing they seem to be trying to
avoid is each other
that might sound fairly familiar to some
of us these days as they navigate the
crowd you can see the Paramecium
actually turn around which is
coordinated by the movement of their
cilia by changing the direction that the
cilia move in the organism is able to
reverse their direction they can also
spin turn or just come to a stop if they
do a number of these reactions in quick
succession the Paramecium can even swim
backwards these movements are a joy to
watch and it is astounding to consider
how a unicellular organism is able to
change its behavior based on its
surroundings but Jennings findings
extended beyond just the notion that an
organism will react to its surroundings
as he continued to prod his denters with
Carman powder he noticed that the
organism began to explore other
strategies to deal with the irritant
when avoiding the Karman failed to stop
the provocation the organism would
temporarily reverse the movement of its
cilia driving the water current away
from the center so it could essentially
spit water out of
mouths and when that didn't work the
Stentor tried to contract away from the
stimulus and when that didn't work well
then the Stentor just up and left
detaching themselves from their
substrate and swimming away in search of
a quieter less Carmen filled home
there's a pretty key implication to
Jennings observations here
thus tenters he observed didn't just
react to stimulus they worked through a
hierarchy of possible responses think of
it the way a cat deals with the common
irritant of a loving human who wants to
cuddle they start with simple evasion
tactics but they might then escalate to
swiping and hissing before just picking
up and running to a corner where they
can't be bothered in the case of
Jennings tenders which fortunately did
not have sharp claws there seemed to be
a ranked preference to the measures they
were gonna take there was just one
problem with Jennings results no one
could replicate them and so for more
than a century his observations were set
aside until a scientist named jeremy
guna Wardner decided to dig deeper and
found that these follow-up studies used
a different Stentor species than
jennings had used when guna Lardner and
his team gathered the original species
Stentor Roselli i they found that their
subjects exhibited those same behaviors
interestingly though different specimens
of the same species seem to have their
own ranked preferences some might only
contract while others would perform a
mix of bending and cilia reversal we
think the stunt errs we've been poking
here are Stentor Roselli eye and if they
are they seem to have preferred that
contraction approached themselves until
they gave in and swam away
for the past few minutes we've been
following one of them as it tries to
find a new home brushing up against
possible substrates with its oral cilia
we think this is part of their
inspection process and if they don't
like what they feel and they swim
backwards and away this little guy has
tried a few locations but here it seems
to have found something intriguing even
as other centers come in and interfere
this one persists returning to inspect
its new found spot again and again like
it's about to make an expensive purchase
and when it's satisfied with its
decision the Stentor releases an
adhesive substance and moves in ready to
eat until the next decision needs to be
made and if that isn't life I don't know
what is it is remarkable to think that
just choosing the wrong species of
Stentor can give such different results
that decision-making even for the
simplest of organisms is such a
complicated endeavor for us to untangle
we are still only at the early stages of
understanding what these actions and
reactions require from different
organisms and for some it is likely to
be much simpler than for others what is
most remarkable as always seems to be
the case with the micro cosmos it's just
how many ways there are to do anything
at all thank you for coming on this
journey with us as we explore the unseen
world that surrounds us if you liked it
the people on screen now are some of the
people you should be thanking because
they are our patrons on patreon and they
allow us to do this wonderful weird
thing if you want to be one of those
people you can go to patreon.com/scishow
we would really appreciate it and thank
you to everybody who supports us we've
really really appreciate it if you want
to see more from our master of
microscopes and james weiss check out
Jam and germs on instagram and if you
want to see more from us
we are at youtube.com slash micro cosmos
[Music]